we will pull it this is a it was a 2021
genesis this is a brand new vehicle
it's one of the corporate sponsor
vehicles from the tournament that had
just concluded
yeah genesis invitational so we're
hoping obviously this can be equipped
with this black box and we'll have some
information
about the the speed it may be a factor
in this accident
i mean you know you could have drivers
in attention
you could have any any type of
distraction like that
speed involved the point of contact
where you hit the center
uh center medium is downhill and it's a
curve
and that stretch of road and people may
be unaware of this but that stretchy
road has
has had quite a few uh accidents over
the years in fact from january of
last year to tiger woods incident
there's a total of 13
accidents four of them with injuries
so definitely this stretch of road is is
challenging and if you're not paying
attention
you can see what happens so this is very
important to know
okay okay another question from steve
gregory kfi
sheriff did a drug recognition expert
respond to the woods crossing or
hospital
no they did not the deputy on scene
assessed the condition of tiger woods
and there was no evidence of any
impairment whatsoever he was lucid no
order of alcohol
no evidence of any uh medication
narcotics or anything like that that
would
uh bring that into question so that was
not a concern at the time so therefore
obviously no field sobriety test and no
dre drug recognition expert
needed to respond to uh do any further
assessment of that this is
what it is an accident okay from abc
news
could tiger woods face charges for
reckless driving
is that part of the investigation no
a reckless driving charge has a lot of
elements into it this is
purely an accident there'll be a cause
of it and there'll be a vehicle code
uh attached to the cause if it's
inattentive driving whatever the case
may be
but that's an infraction and a reckless
driving is actually more than an
infraction
that's a misdemeanor crime that has a
lot of elements attached to it and
there's nothing
nothing like that okay
okay we have a okay abc news again have
investigators question mr woods if not
any idea when they will
actually the unseen deputy who was first
there
is a traffic deputy he is the one who is
going to be doing the traffic
investigation so
he has all the information he needs from
mr woods
and after that uh
and and then they'll become part of his
investigation once it's concluded and
submitted to his supervisors for
his approval okay from steven diazo ap
are charges possible in the crash uh we
don't contemplate any charges whatsoever
in this crash this remains an accident
accident is not a crime
they do happen unfortunately and uh okay
let's see here okay were photos taken by
offers at the scene
yes photos were taken there's body
cam footage that was taken however these
are official photographs it'll be part
of
the investigation itself and they're not
going to be
released from us okay natalie salazar
deputy gonzalez has done an excellent
job speaking to the press recruit him to
share his information
natalie i've got more than one person
saying exactly that and uh
yeah our our deputies at siv are feeling
a little nervous right now
okay and another question here was he
drunk he was not drunk
that that is um definitely we can throw
that one out
speculation irresponsible no there was
no evidence of any impairment i said
that
yesterday and and that's just the fact
we're going to call the way there if
there was evidence of that
well then that we proceed with that
however and we hold everyone accountable
to the rule of law
no matter what your celebrity status is
but there was no evidence of that
so this is an accident we're treating as
an accident
okay okay
any other let me see
okay okay we have some questions here
okay uh
okay uh any idea he was distracted and
looking at the phone
uh we do not have any information on
that whatsoever i mean we'll
we'll find out on that and uh
i'm sure his phone records might be
relevant to that itself
and that's gonna be up to the
investigators and
they will require a search warrant for
that just for example if there was an
issue about uh
if he was under uh under the influence
of some type of prescribed medication
for example
or they did any blood work at the
hospital that would also require a
search warrant
to be able to seize that information
it's part of the investigation but
that's gonna be up to the traffic
investigator
to do that okay
let's see um
okay okay
okay thanks sheriff so to confirm on
that stretch you wrote alone there were
13 accidents
four with injuries since last january
yes
matt gutman that is that is accurate we
got that information yesterday
okay let me see
okay the speed limit posted for that
stretcher road if people are wondering
is 45 now
remember this 45 that's the maximum
speed limit however
section 22 350 the vehicle code when
you're sighted for that unsafe speed
that's unsafe speed for the driving
condition conditions for example
if the road was foggy which in this case
it wasn't but if it was foggy
rainy well you don't do the 45
limit it's actually lower than that it's
for the driving conditions at the time
and that is the maximum and optimal
condition
at 45 miles per hour and this pressure
road going downhill on a curve
obviously even if you're not
accelerating just by gravity alone you
can start going faster in fact
there's a turnout for trucks and a
warning about testing your brakes
okay let's see will was be tested for
drugs and alcohol or was he tested
yesterday last night at the hospital
that would be up to the hospital to do
that toxicology
and we'll assume that during the course
of the treatment they draw blood
and they have to do that obviously
because he has to go into into surgery
and all that
but that's going to require a search
warrant from our part
to go into those details okay
now let's see here okay
and i don't know who this came from uh
let me point out that professionalism
and knowledge displayed by deputy
gonzalez yesterday
is a representation of what 99 of our
lsd personnel do that is very true
and um he's only got three years in
patrol god bless him doing a good
good job definitely he's showing how
it's done now i'm gonna
translate i'm gonna switch over to
spanish and you can continue asking the
questions in english and we'll we'll
catch up to them
tiger
oh
is
tiger woods
yes
okay
[Music]
kevin from cnn do you know where tiger
woods was traveling from
and where he crashed and where was he
driving to
i've heard that he was going to a golf
course to continue filming something he
was filming the day before
i think the roller hills rolling hills
estates golf course
was about four miles away from the scene
of the accident
so that's all we have in spanish
is
[Music]
okay uh let me see ktla fire the crash
happened around 7 15 we didn't learn of
it
four hours uh why the delay
good question
well actually at the point when the
crash happened our focus is on providing
the medical care making sure
everything is taken care of the scene is
secured and we're doing everything we're
doing the paramedics
and the fire department did everything
they did and once he's at the hospital
everything is secured
then is the time that we can start okay
this is going to be obviously a
newsworthy event
and we prepared a statement and we
released it and that's the right order
of things
when people jump the gun and release
information without knowing it
without affected family members being
notified
it does a lot of harm we want to respect
the privacy of the people involved as
much as we can
and this is uh but remember health and
safety is always a priority first and
once all these things are taken care of
and the victim's family is notified
and then we can go into okay let's
notify the press
and do all these things so so you can
understand why that that's the four-hour
delay there
okay let's see here
okay i think we're going to call it on
that and
espanol okay
oh one more here we got one okay from
david douglas to nbc news
we do not ow oh there's a question about
speed again we do not know his estimated
speed at this time
but the investigation hopefully is going
to address that
since there are no skid marks and
obvious things we can determine speed
we have to go to the black box that the
vehicle has one and other things to
estimate
that speed all right and having said
that let me
close by saying please folks remember
we're
still in the pandemic and we got to keep
wearing these masks get your vaccination
when your time comes
make sure you jump on and get that
vaccination all right everyone
and uh we're going to be doing this
instagram and facebook every wednesday
we're on run this time frame you know
time permitting obviously no no
disasters happening
and last but not least we want to wish a
full
and complete recovery for tiger woods so
let's keep him and his family in our
prayers all right
with that said all right everyone have a
good day